.
Wie sieht es aus mit der
Kanalisation, dem Gas und allem?
Das mit dem Gas
klären wir momentan ab.
Es gibt immer wieder Probleme.
Das dauert immer wahnsinnig lange.
Das ist die Septic,
die Kanalisation, die wir einbauen.
Das gibt es ganz neu.
Normalerweise gräbt man nur ein Loch
und pumpt alles ab.
Aber unsere nette Nachbarin
macht uns die Hölle heiss.
Das hatte sich der Baselbieter
Roland Tschopp anders vorgestellt.
Ausgerechnet hier
auf der Schwarzmeer-Halbinsel Krim,
einem Hotspot der Geopolitik,
wollte er ein Haus bauen
mit ein paar Ferienwohnungen,
um zusammen mit seiner Frau Karyna
das Leben und den Ruhestand
zu geniessen.
War das rückblickend
nicht etwas naiv?
Naiv?
Vielleicht kann man das
im Nachhinein so sagen.
Die Krim ist mir ans Herz gewachsen.
Ich fühle mich dort sehr wohl,
habe darin eine Chance gesehen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte Musik *
Das erste Mal traf ich
Roland Tschopp im Sommer 2019.
Damals lebte er
zusammen mit seiner Frau Karyna
in Läufelfingen
auf diesem Campingplatz.
(Roland Tschopp)
Das ist der Ess- und Wohnraum.
Hier haben wir
ein kleines Schlafzimmer.
Es ist natürlich sehr klein.
Sind Sie glücklich hier?
* Sie seufzt, dann lachen beide. *
Der Baselbieter
hat alles auf eine Karte gesetzt:
Wohnung verkauft,
seine Metallbaufirma verkauft –
und eine neue gegründet,
TSCHOPP's Krimreise.
War das schwierig ...
- Ja.
... der Umzug hierher?
- Für mich war es ganz schwierig.
Das hier ist ganz klein und ...
... aus Plastik.
Natürlich war ich unzufrieden.
Aber jetzt
habe ich mich daran gewöhnt.
Aber es ist schon speziell:
Ihr Mann will als Schweizer
in Ihre Heimat gehen
und Sie wollen hier bleiben.
Ja, das ist sehr speziell.
Ich weiss nicht,
was ihn dort so interessiert.
Heute Abend
fliegen die beiden auf die Krim,
die alte Heimat von Karyna.
Vor sieben Jahren haben sie sich
im Internet kennengelernt
und später geheiratet.
Roli kommt. Hallo, Schätzchen.
Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Pizza speziell, Schätzchen.
Für Roland ist das Haus auf der Krim
eine Flucht nach vorne.
Nach einem Herzinfarkt
und einem Burn-out ist er überzeugt,
dass er auf der Krim
ein längeres Leben vor sich hat
als in der Schweiz.
Das ist der Tablettenvorrat
für vier Wochen.
Tabletten?
- (Roland und Karyna) Ja.
Bereitet dir die medizinische
Versorgung keine Sorgen?
Ich werde des Öfteren gefragt,
ob ich keine Angst davor habe.
Ich sage mir immer:
Wenn ich in der Schweiz geblieben
und so weitergearbeitet hätte,
hätte ich hier eher
einen erneuten Herzinfarkt erlitten.
Auf der Krim habe ich weniger
Stress, es herrscht ein gutes Klima.
Ich bin nicht unter Druck.
So kommt es nicht mehr zum Infarkt.
Das ist meine Philosophie.
* Sanfte
Streich- und Gitarrenmusik *
* Kinderrufe *
Karyna und Rolands Ziel:
die Stadt Jewpatorija.
Ein Touristenort im Westen der Krim.
* Gemächliche Folkmusik *
Die Gäste kommen v.a. aus Russland.
Westliche und ukrainische
Besucherinnen und Besucher
sind hier selten geworden.
Eine Folge
der internationalen Sanktionen.
Wenn die Tschopps in der Stadt sind,
wohnen sie in einer Mietwohnung.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Roland und Karyna
sind schon ein paar Tage vor mir
auf die Krim gekommen.
Mit einem Flug über Moskau.
Damit verletzten sie ukrainisches
Recht, was sie in Kauf nehmen.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Ich selber
fahre auf dem offiziellen Weg
durch die Ukraine in Richtung Krim.
Die Krim ist ein Streitobjekt
zwischen Russland und dem Westen.
Seit der Annexion der ukrainischen
Halbinsel durch Russland
vor sechs Jahren
ist hier faktisch eine Grenze.
Zuerst geht es
an den ukrainischen Behörden vorbei,
dann an den russischen.
Wie die meisten hier bringe ich
die paar Hundert Meter Niemandsland
zu Fuss hinter mich -
eine spannungsgeladene Stimmung.
Mit allen Kontrollen und Befragungen
kann das Stunden dauern.
Von Reisen auf die Krim rät
die offizielle Schweiz übrigens ab.
Aus Sicht der Schweiz
und vieler anderer Länder
bin ich hier völkerrechtlich
nach wie vor in der Ukraine.
Aber es ist Russland, das die Krim
derzeit unter seiner Kontrolle hat.
Winter 2014.
(Frau) Rossiya! Rossiya! Rossiya!
Russland schickt militärische Sonder-
einheiten auf die ukrainische Krim.
Nach einem umstrittenen Referendum
erklärt der Kreml
die Krim als Teil Russlands.
Viele Krim-Bewohner
unterstützen das -
und tun es bis heute.
Andere, insbesondere viele
unter den muslimischen Krimtataren,
wehren sich dagegen.
Eine illegale Annexion,
sagt die Mehrheit der UNO-Staaten.
(Sprechgesänge)
Ukrayna! Free Ukrayna!
* Er spricht russisch. *
Mit Kampfjets
und schwerem Kriegsmaterial
demonstriert der russische Präsident
Wladimir Putin
seither seine Bereitschaft, die Krim
mit allen Mitteln zu verteidigen.
Auf der Insel
führt er ein autoritäres Regime ein.
Russland hat inzwischen geschätzte
20 Mrd. Fr. hier investiert.
U.a. in neue Strassen und eine
Brücke zum russischen Festland.
Die Ukraine und der Westen
haben mit Sanktionen reagiert.
So können Roland und Karyna
auf der Krim
z.B. ihre Schweizer Handys oder
ihre Kreditkarten nicht gebrauchen.
Trotz internationaler Sanktionen
sind hier die Regale
in den Verkaufsläden voll.
Dank russischer Gelder sind die Löhne
und Renten auf der Krim gestiegen,
aber auch die Preise
sind in die Höhe geschnellt.
Es gibt viel Bürokratie
und Korruption.
Insgesamt ist die wirtschaftliche
Bilanz der Annexion
für Russland ziemlich ernüchternd.
Roland Tschopp sagt,
er wisse wenig
über die politische Situation.
Er äussert sich pragmatisch.
Siehst du das hier
als Ukraine oder Russland?
Ich denke, hier ist es sicherer,
wenn es zu Russland gehört.
Auch wenn man an die Zukunft denkt.
Die Russen investieren sehr viel -
in die Infrastruktur,
in den Tourismus etc.
Ich finde es besser,
wenn es Russland ist.
* Gemächliche, verspielte Musik *
Die Baustelle der Tschopps
liegt etwas ausserhalb der Stadt,
rund 2 km vom Meer entfernt.
Seit 2017 bauen sie hier.
Geplant sind eine Wohnung für sich
und vier Ferienwohnungen.
Wie läuft's?
* Roland stöhnt leise. *
* Der Journalist lacht. *
Die Leute sind das Problem.
Sind es zu wenige
oder sind sie nicht gut genug?
Sie sind nicht gut genug.
Im nächsten Jahr können wir
wohl noch nicht vermieten.
Der nächste Sommer
wäre also vorgesehen gewesen?
Ja, das wird aber nicht reichen.
Das Dach
müssen wir komplett neu machen.
Die haben Mist gebaut.
- Ach ja?
Ja.
- Was ist passiert?
Für die
ist das eine neue Technologie.
Das sind Rollen, die sie
zum ersten Mal verbaut haben.
Es hat Wellen drin ... Katastrophal.
Jetzt gibt es ein Blechdach.
Aber irgendwann wird das hier unten
schon noch mein Domizil werden.
Mal schauen, wie Karyna mitmacht,
wann sie hierher kommen will.
Sie will in der Schweiz bleiben?
- Ja.
* Nachdenkliche Klavierklänge *
Karyna
ist noch nicht davon überzeugt,
wieder in ihre ehemalige Heimat Krim
zu ziehen.
Sie hat im Baselbiet bei der Spitex
einen Teilzeitjob als Pflegehelferin.
Den will sie nicht aufgeben.
Aber wenn sie auf der Krim ist,
übernimmt sie
aufgrund ihrer Sprachkenntnisse
viel von der Organisation.
Sie haben ein Problem.
- Wer?
Aktuell gibt es ein Problem
mit den armenischen Bauarbeitern.
Wieder wurde etwas angefangen
und nicht fertiggestellt.
Wie lange geht das?
- Zwei Wochen.
Was ist los?
Die Armenier gehen jetzt.
- Die Armenier?
Ja, die kommen
erst in zwei Wochen wieder.
Mit der Garage
geht es also nicht voran.
Die Leute, die hier entladen
sollten, suchen uns irgendwo.
Der Bagger hat Probleme
mit der Hydraulik.
* Er lacht. *
* Sanfte
Streich- und Gitarrenmusik *
15 Jahre hatte Roland Tschopp
nicht mehr geraucht.
Die ständigen Verzögerungen
sind nervenzehrend
und gehen an den Geldbeutel.
Der Traum vom ruhigen Leben
auf der Krim droht zu platzen.
Die grösste Herausforderung
ist der Streit mit der Nachbarin.
Sie reicht immer wieder Beschwerden
bei den Behörden ein,
ruft die Polizei
und achtet penibel darauf,
dass die Bauvorschriften
eingehalten werden.
* Gemächliche Folkmusik *
Zu Beginn klappte alles sehr gut.
Zwei Equipen haben hier gearbeitet.
Die Nachbarin hat uns
die Polizei auf den Hals gehetzt.
Es stellte sich heraus, dass die
Arbeiter keine Bewilligung hatten.
Deshalb musste die Equipe
zurück nach Hause in die Ukraine.
Du sprichst von Arbeitern
ohne Bewilligung.
Bewegt sich hier normalerweise
alles im Halblegalen?
Das gibt es oft.
Hätte die Nachbarin nichts gesagt,
wäre es kein Problem gewesen?
Nein.
Wegen der Nachbarin
mussten alle ihren Pass hinterlegen,
Steuern bezahlen usw.
Wir mussten auch
den Anwalt einsetzen,
Arbeitsverträge aufsetzen etc.
Alles ist einfach mühsamer.
Aus meiner Zeit in Russland
und der Ukraine weiss ich,
dass beim Bauen
vieles nicht angemeldet wird.
Ich möchte diese Nachbarin
gerne mal treffen.
* Angespannte Klänge *
(Mann) Klopf lauter.
(Frau) Das von ihnen dort
ist doch kein Wohnhaus.
Schauen Sie meins an.
Das ist ein Wohnhaus,
oder diejenigen der Nachbaren.
Aber sie hier
haben kommerzielle Ferienwohnungen.
Die wollen hier Business machen.
Aber ein Business?
Mit 30 Gästen?
Das wird's nicht geben.
Es gibt nun mal Gesetze
in unserem Land.
Und an diese muss man sich halten.
Wir kamen
aus der Hauptstadt Simferopol
und haben das Haus
extra hier gebaut.
In der Einöde.
Etwas weiter vom Meer weg.
Weil wir keine Touristen
um uns haben wollten.
Wir wollen Ruhe.
Wenn sie ein Business wollen,
wieso bauen sie dann nicht am Meer?
Weil es dort teurer ist.
Sie wollen sparen
auf Kosten meiner Nerven.
Inzwischen haben die Tschopps
ihr Haus offiziell als
kommerzielles Ferienhaus angemeldet.
Dafür müssen sie jetzt
mehr Steuern zahlen.
Klar ist:
Den unbürokratischen Weg zu bauen,
wird es hier mit dieser Nachbarin für
die Baselbieter wohl kaum mehr geben.
Sie wird immer wieder
etwas suchen und finden.
Wir wollten das Gas anmelden.
Sie hat bereits einen Brief
ans Gasamt geschrieben.
Deshalb gibt es mehrere Abklärungen,
obwohl alles
relativ einfach gewesen wäre.
Das ist immer ein Stolperstein.
Dank ihr läuft alles rechtmässig?
- Ja, richtig.
(Ironisch) Dank ihr.
(Lachend) Da hast du dich
auf etwas eingelassen, was?
Das kann man wohl sagen.
Eine Herausforderung.
Wie viel sie hier investiert haben,
wollen die Tschopps nicht sagen.
Aber es ist mehr als geplant.
Nebst dem Schicksal
der Familie Tschopp
interessiere ich mich auch für die
politische Situation auf der Krim.
Ich erfahre, dass zwei der Arbeiter
Krimtataren sind.
Viele Krimtataren seien
seit der Annexion durch Russland
in einer schwierigen Situation,
heisst es.
Könnt ihr mir erzählen,
wie es den Krimtataren heute geht?
Das ist so eine Sache.
Wir haben Kinder,
die machen noch ihre Ausbildungen.
Ist es gefährlich, zu reden?
Nicht, dass ich mich fürchten würde.
Aber Sie wissen ja,
es kann allerhand passieren.
Dann geben sie mir den Kontakt
eines Tatarenführers, der offen rede.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Rund 200'000 Tataren
leben auf der Krim,
etwa 10 % der Gesamtbevölkerung.
Gemäss russischen Menschen-
rechtsorganisationen und der UNO
sind Tataren seit
der Machtübernahme durch Russland
politischen Repressionen ausgesetzt.
Kritisiert werden u.a. willkürliche
Verhaftungen und auch Folter.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Der regionale Tatarenvertreter
sieht derzeit wenig Raum
für politische Forderungen.
Wie war die Annexion
für Sie emotional?
Das war damals
ein grosser Schock für uns.
Wir haben offiziell gesagt, dass wir
die Annexion nicht anerkennen
und unsere Rechte verteidigen.
Aber dann wurde unsere politische
Volksvertretung, der Medschlis,
von den Russen verboten.
Und wie leben die Tataren jetzt
auf der Krim?
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich selber
erkläre es unseren Leuten immer so:
"Was hast du? Schafe?
Dann schau nach ihnen."
"Erziehe und ernähre deine Kinder.
Wir rufen dich nicht zum Protest."
"Hast du ein Gewächshaus?
Dann pflanze Gemüse an."
"Erziehe deine Kinder. Und lebe.
Wir werden diese Zeit überstehen."
"Wenn der Protest beginnt,
rufen wir dich."
Aber unter den derzeitigen
Machthabern ist das zwecklos.
Sie finden dich sofort,
hängen dir irgendetwas an und
dann sperren sie dich ins Gefängnis.
Viele von uns sitzen im Gefängnis.
* Sprechgesang *
Die Tataren
sind grösstenteils Muslime.
Ihren Glauben
dürfen sie relativ frei ausüben
und auch ihre eigene tatarische
Sprache sprechen und lehren.
* Er spricht tatarisch. *
Die teils herrschende Abneigung
gegenüber den Russen
ist historisch begründet.
Stalin liess 1944
praktisch die gesamte
tatarische Bevölkerung deportieren.
Erst gegen Ende der Sowjetunion
durften sie wieder
auf die Krim zurück.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Das Drama der Deportation
prägt sie bis heute.
Ich bin in dieser Region geboren.
1944 wurden wir deportiert.
Ich war damals zwölf Jahre alt.
Sie weckten uns in der Nacht,
warfen uns aus den Häusern
und karrten uns weg.
(Wimmernd)
Entschuldigung, meine Nerven.
44 Jahre
habe ich dann in Usbekistan gelebt.
Dann durfte ich wieder
in meine Heimat.
Ich bin sehr froh,
in der Heimat zu sein.
* Helle Klänge *
Die politischen Turbulenzen
sind für Roland Tschopp,
der kaum Russisch versteht,
weit weg.
Er hat genug Sorgen
mit der Baustelle.
Diese drei Wohnungen
sind jetzt gemacht.
Jetzt werden diese hier
und die dort noch gemacht.
Der Bau
strapaziert die Nerven des Paares.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Wenn ihr es so macht,
dann seht ihr jedes Mal das Rohr.
Einfach damit ihr es wisst.
Aber ich halte mich raus.
Ich bin dann mal weg.
Macht's gut.
Ich möchte das so, Karyna.
Ich diskutiere nicht mit dir.
Du hast diskutiert.
Es spielt keine Rolle,
ob hier oder hier ...
Doch.
Ich möchte es hier in der Mitte.
Wenn oben der Hahn ist, sind die
Anschlüsse unten bei der Schublade.
Wenn etwas ist,
kannst du die Schublade noch öffnen.
Das ist hier
hinter der Schublade versteckt.
Ich möchte das bitte hier
in der Mitte haben, wie andere auch.
Basta.
Okay? Ja?
- Mhm.
Sicher?
- Ja.
(Ironisch) Ja, ja. Sicher?
Gut.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Ich verreise heute Abend.
Aber mein Mann bleibt hier.
Und, wie ist der Abschied vom Haus?
Es ist alles in Ordnung, alles gut.
- Und emotional?
Wir sind schon ruhiger,
vieles ist getan.
Entschuldigen Sie,
ich bin etwas müde.
* Sie räuspert sich. *
Wir haben jetzt
ein gutes Fundament gelegt.
In den nächsten Monaten müssen wir
noch den Rohbau fertig machen.
Ich denke,
bis Neujahr ist es so weit.
Aber noch ohne den Innenausbau.
Jetzt ist aber die grosse Frage,
woher wir für die nächste Etappe
das Geld nehmen sollen.
Karynas Aufenthalte auf der
heimischen Krim sind meist kurz.
Im Baselbiet wartet ihre Arbeit
als Spitex-Mitarbeiterin.
Roland wird für fast drei Monate
alleine hierbleiben.
Telefonnummer.
* Karyna wimmert leise. *
* Sie unterhalten sich leise. *
Du auch, ja?
- Ja.
Danke. Mach's gut.
Einen guten Flug.
Komm gut nach Hause.
* Sie spricht leise zu Roland. *
Ja, mache ich. Tschüss.
Ciao.
- Ciao, ciao.
Nimm bitte jeden Tag
die Medikamente. - Ja, ja.
Ciao, ciao. Tschüss.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Ich komme Ende November, Schätzchen.
Pass auf dich auf.
- Du auch, bitte.
Trink genug Wasser.
Und wenig rauchen.
- Ja, ja. Gut. Ich versuche es.
Ciao, ciao.
- Tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
* Der Motor startet. *
Ciao, ciao, ciao.
* Verspielte, jazzige Musik *
Es ist Oktober im Baselbiet.
* Surren *
So. Vielen Dank.
(Frau) Karyn!
- Jawohl.
(Euphorisch) Ci si vede.
- Ja.
Ja.
- Hallo, hallo.
Ciao.
- Ciao, ciao.
So.
Du warst lange nicht mehr hier.
- Ja.
Karyn.
- Ja, schon lange nicht mehr.
Sempre uguale, il lavoro.
- Ja.
Schon lange nicht mehr.
- Jawohl.
Aber ich arbeite noch hier.
Ich war eine Woche in den Ferien.
Adesso io sono stata in Italia.
Ach ja?
E le zanzare hanno fatto ... bis da.
- Oh.
Unten ... Aha.
- Ja, viel.
Aha.
- Viele zanzare.
Schreibe:
"Cara Maria, ti voglio bene."
Freude, Karyn.
- Freuen Sie sich? Schön.
Ja, sehr.
Sono molto, molto contenta.
- Molto contenta? Okay.
Sie ist sehr nett.
Ganz, ganz nett. Sehr nett.
Schön.
So.
- Ciao. E grazie.
Würden Sie die Arbeit
für die Krim aufgeben?
Nein, nein, ich liebe meine Arbeit
bei der Spitex.
Die möchte ich nicht aufgeben.
Später schauen wir dann mal -
vielleicht.
Aber ich arbeite
mit grossem Vergnügen.
Und das
möchte ich auch weiterhin tun.
* Sanfte
Streich- und Gitarrenmusik *
In dieser Zeit schickt mir
Roland Tschopp regelmässig Fotos.
Es gehe gut vorwärts mit dem Bau.
Er fühle sich wohl und würde
am liebsten auf der Krim bleiben.
* Gemächliche Folkmusik *
Aber es zeichnet sich auch schon ab,
dass das Geld ausgeht.
Für den vollständigen Innenausbau
wird es nicht mehr reichen.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Es ist Mitte Dezember 2019.
Ich fahre nochmals zum Campingplatz
von Läufelfingen.
Roland ist vor Kurzem
von der Krim zurückgekehrt.
Ich habe eine schlechte Nachricht
für ihn.
Hallo.
- Kurzes Haar.
Ich habe sie geschnitten.
- Ein Sommerschnitt.
Hallo, Christof. Nicht so fest.
- Wie geht's? Oh, pardon.
* Bellen *
Hallo. Wie heisst du noch mal?
Walt.
- Salut, Walt.
Hallo.
- Hallo, wie geht's?
Es gibt ein Problem.
- Welches?
Für mich und für dich.
Das wollte ich dir zeigen.
Kennst du das hier?
Sagt dir das etwas?
- Nein, gar nichts.
Wie ich erfahren habe,
gibt es anscheinend Sanktionen
der Schweiz gegen die Krim.
So sind dort Investitionen verboten
und auch die Erbringung
touristischer Aktivitäten.
Ich habe mich nie wirklich
damit auseinandergesetzt.
Ich mich auch nicht.
- Was heisst das? Keine Sendung?
Na ja,
jetzt müssen wir weiterschauen.
Hier steht: "Verbot des Erwerbs
und Ausweitung von Beteiligung
an Unternehmen und Immobilien
auf der Krim."
Ich bin aber mit
einer russischen Frau verheiratet,
die von dort kommt.
Zweitens: "Erbringungsverbot
von Dienstleistung im Zusammenhang
mit tourismusbezogenen Aktivitäten
auf der Krim."
* Angespannte Klänge *
Nach kurzer Besprechung ist klar,
wie wir weitermachen wollen.
Wenn das für dich in Ordnung ist,
kläre ich das mit dem SECO ab.
Ohne zu sagen, wer ...
- Anonym.
Es gebe diesen bestimmten Fall,
wir hätten das gefilmt.
Einfach, was läuft.
- Ja, genau.
Ist das für dich okay?
- Das ist für mich okay.
Das Staatssekretariat für Wirtschaft
SECO schrieb mir:
Ob ein Straftatbestand vorliege,
könne nur aufgrund
der genauen Kenntnis der Fakten
und dem Vorliegen entsprechender
Dokumente beurteilt werden.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Mittlerweile ist es Sommer 2020.
Roland Tschopp
hat wegen der Sanktionen reagiert.
Er hat die TSCHOPP GmbH Krimreisen
in der Schweiz aufgelöst,
und in Russland eine neue gegründet.
Das Haus auf der Krim
läuft ohnehin auf den Namen
seiner russischen Frau Karyna.
Doch für Roland
war es auch sonst ein schweres Jahr.
Die Baustelle auf der Krim
stand wegen Corona still.
Sein geliebter Hund starb.
Aber das ist noch nicht alles.
In diesem Jahr ist viel passiert.
Karyna ist auch nicht mehr bei mir.
Sie ist ausgezogen.
Das ist auf eine Art ...
verständlich.
Denn in den zwei Jahren ...
... seit ich alles verkaufen konnte,
Rheuma in den Händen,
Schmerzen hatte usw.,
war ich natürlich ...
... nicht gerade der beste Ehemann.
Ich war oft gereizt,
die Stimmung war schlecht.
An und für sich auf der Krim ...
Ist es definitiv?
- Was?
Habt ihr euch einfach mal getrennt?
Sie meinte,
sie komme nicht mehr zurück.
Ja.
Aber das Verhältnis, das wir jetzt
noch pflegen, ist eigentlich gut.
Sie kommt alle zwei Wochen vorbei
und bringt etwas Katzenfutter.
Das Bauprojekt auf der Krim wollen
beide unbedingt zu Ende führen.
Es bleibt aber schwierig.
Geld ist fast keines mehr da.
Roland
hat inzwischen Sozialhilfe beantragt.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wie viel fehlt noch?
Für den Bau
fehlen noch ca. 30'000 Euro.
Das wären ...
Wenn 20 Leute
im Voraus buchen würden,
könnten wir im nächsten Jahr
mit dem Vermieten beginnen.
Im ersten Jahr
werden wir nicht viel einnehmen.
Das hängt auch davon ab,
wie sich Corona entwickelt.
Aber es würde ...
Die ganze Sache
würde 100%ig funktionieren.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt, was?
* Entfernte Vogelpfiffe *
* Sanfte
Streich- und Gitarrenmusik *
Das Letzte, was ich von Karyna
und Roland gehört habe:
Sie waren zusammen in Hamburg,
um einen neuen Hund zu kaufen.
* Gemächliche Folkmusik *
Tschopps Traum vom Haus auf der Krim
ist noch nicht ganz ausgeträumt.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2020